so of course isis released the beheading
video of journalist alan henning
earlier this month now it sounds like uh
there may be another beheading today
today is wednesday uh and at the end of
the alan henning video they promised to
behead american journalist peter kasig
so we'll see if they if that happens uh
but interestingly yesterday
video was released of what appears to be
american aid that was supposed to be
dropped for the kurds
to fight isis but surprise surprise it
ended up in isis's hands let's take a
look
foreign
okay so that hasn't been independently
confirmed so it's a little unclear when
exactly that was dropped some people are
saying
some of the stuff may be from somewhere
else but it's clear that a lot of it is
american made
we got a huge situation going on on the
uh
turkish syrian border in the town kobani
which is where the kurds are fighting
isis the turks are kind of fighting the
kurds
everyone's just fighting everybody we're
sort of bombing people we don't know
what the hell is going on
it's a big freaking mess ben rhodes
who's the white house press secretary
he commented earlier this week about
dropping aid and who it's getting to
we feel very confident that we've been
able to hit the target in terms of
reaching the people
we want to reach what i can assure
people is that when we are delivering
aid now we focus it on the people we
want to receive
that assistance those are civilians in
need those are forces that we're aligned
with in the fight against isil and we
take precautions to make sure that it's
not falling into the wrong hands
and then there's the video that you just
saw so you're like every week we do
something about isis and it's a big
freaking mess and i feel like we're
we're
aiding the wrong people half the time we
don't know who our allies are people are
helping us they're not helping us
so does any of this surprise you in any
way well you know this is this goes back
to the whole thing where
you had the hawks the hawk republicans
in congress were like oh we're going to
support the right
syrian rebels and not the wrong syrian
rebels and
yeah of course this stuff's going to
wind up in the wrong hands i mean you
know we armed al qaeda to fight the
russians and then
face our own guns ourselves this is a
history of this stuff yeah so it's just
obvious like we see these videos like i
saw the video immediately i was like of
course
this just is so sad bad homeland episode
or something
yeah it's it's definitely it seems like
the the sort of early healthcare.gov of
military operations i mean i can't
believe
but there's like there's people doubters
online saying that this is like a
falsified
video right from yeah well of course
there's all the conspiracy theorists and
if you go to infowars.com
what's his name who's the guy at
infowars uh alex
alex jones babbling on about all the
conspiracies and is the cia really isis
and all that stuff
i don't know what the hell is going on
but what i when i see these videos
it makes me realize how important the
social media game it's like how how much
do you think that that really you know
we've discussed
can we show these videos how much of the
beheading stuff should be shown
twitter isn't posting them anymore how
important do you think the social media
game is
to both sides well you know i mean
obviously the the the game has changed
it's not like where
you know uh osama bin laden would send
his new videotape to the networks and
they would hope they would show it now
it's you've got everybody's got a direct
conduit and so
yeah four guys out of a job well you
know
the the press liaison for al-qaeda yeah
so sadly
no and so yeah i mean i think that we've
seen it work in both directions you know
it
can bring to light something like the uh
you know the
the tareer square protests or whatever
but at the same time yeah these guys can
use it
and i'm sure while twitter's trying to
crack down on it and i think people are
starting to realize oh maybe i shouldn't
share the beheading video on my facebook
wall
it's still going to be going around and
they they are they've got a direct link
to people that they didn't have before
yeah they're using it to recruit too
sure yeah it's scary is this the
inherent problem with sort of doing a
half war
now i've been against this thing from
the beginning we didn't get
congressional authority to go to war in
syria it was still unclear whether we
had that to even do anything in iraq
anymore but
we don't even talk about that anymore um
but is this part of it when you just
when you just do airstrikes as opposed
to doing more not that i'm saying we
should do more
that this is good what's going to happen
because you're going to bomb people and
just drop things
as opposed to having things on the
ground where you can literally hand
weapons to people or hand
food to people et cetera you think that
would be capable of more accuracy what
with like drone technology and stuff
like that right
we're just not that good we're always
afraid of drones so they're just not
that great it's
crazy to me that we can put a robot on
mars and yet we can't
accurately drop ammunition where it
needs to be yeah um final thought on
this
do you think the military industrial
complex actually cares where the weapons
end up because that's the other thing i
started thinking like ah
you know what they dropped those well
that just means they have to drop more
for the other guys
so it's like the machine just keeps it
right if they could arm both sides they
would yeah
that's where the money is i'm pretty
sure that's totally yeah do it scary
thought
yeah i don't think there's any qualms on
any part about this